I'm Jacqueline Nolis.
This is my presentation.
How one time I made an entire
e-commerce platform on Shiny.
They said it couldn't
be done, but I did it.
What is that platform?
That platform is ggirl,
which is to make
your ggplots in real life.
Some people may pronounce it g-girl, but it is officially GG-IRL.
You can install it via
remotes::install_github("jnolis/ggirl")
and what it does is it
lets you take a ggplot you've
made that's beautiful
that you wish existed
in the physical realm.
You can then pay a modest
fee and very soon you
will get an actual postcard
delivered to a friend or family
member.
But it's all cool
to talk about it.
Let's actually see how it works
instead.
So I'm going to immediately
switch out of PowerPoint
and switch to a live demo.
So I'm running this
in Saturn cloud.
I'm just going to
open up RStudio.
And so let's say
you have a plot you
like let's say you have this
souvenir commemorative--
Oh, oh, no.
I think we're also.
Yeah, we're missing it.
Is it not showing up. Wait, here?
Can I do this?
Yeah cool.
Good! That would've been tragic.
This is the best part.
Here we go.
Let's see if I can
do this from over here.
Yes! OK, great.
Let's say you have this souvenir
commemorative ggirl plot.
Oh, god, I'm going to
have to do it like this.
Oh, no, I see it.
We're good.
OK, so you have the souvenir
commemorative ggirl plot.
You can then go and you can use
this ggpostcard() function which
takes a plot, the contact email
for the order confirmation,
the message you want
to put on the back
of the postcard like "This
is a great conference,
Thanks for putting it on!" and the
address of a friend or family
member. In this case,
I'm going to send it to
our friends at RStudio--
I mean Posit--in
Boston, Massachusetts.
So in several weeks,
their headquarters
is going to be confused
why they got a postcard.
But here we are.
So I'm going to hit that.
And what's going
to happen is it's
going to think for
a second and then
it's going to launch an
entirely separate Shiny Server.
This is a Shiny Server
running somewhere else.
It is not running
on my computer.
It is running actually
on Saturn cloud.
So on the front you can see
the preview of the postcard.
It shows you the message.
It shows you the address.
It has one button and
that's "Pay and Submit"
when you hit Pay and Submit.
Oh, god, this is so hard.
There we go.
OK, great.
When you hit Pay and Submit,
it thinks for a second
and sends you to Stripe.
In Stripe, it asks
you for money.
So I'm going to go ahead and put
in my credit card information.
Just kidding,
Cyber stalkers!
So you do that.
And then if you did somehow put
in your credit card information
in front of a bunch of people,
you would then very soon
get an email confirming
that you made the order
and in one to two weeks you
will get a physical postcard
of your ggplot.
That's right.
The first presentation you've
seen with physical props.
Your message is on the back.
It's got the ggirl hex sticker.
Oh, I think I just doxxed
myself and my address.
Cool OK, so now we're back
to PowerPoint and let's
see if I can pop this back up.
Let me see.
You got it?
OK, great.
Cool, cool.
So that was the demo.
As you saw, it went from R
to a Shiny app to Stripe
and then somehow a
postcard appeared.
But how does it work?
How does it work?
There we go.
OK, so there's an
R package called ggirl.
That's what you install on your
computer and it talks to the Shiny
Server.
And then there is a Shiny Server
called ggirl-server, which
does all the work of
showing the user preview,
passing the
information to Stripe,
fulfilling the
postcard via an API.
So there's a service somewhere
I call to make the post card go
and then sends a
confirmation email.
Now if you think
about it, ggirl-server
should be multiple Shiny
apps and plumber APIs.
There is no reason why
the fulfillment, why
the uploading the information
should be done via Shiny.
It's better, probably better to
do that as an API via plumber,
but for ease of
maintenance, I'm like,
I really just want one
Shiny app to do all of this.
And by ease of maintenance,
I mean I'm super lazy
and I don't want to have to
keep a bunch of microservices
running.
I just want one.
But to make this
work leads a lot
of engineering questions, which
I'm going to enumerate now.
One is how do you pass
the plot from R to Shiny?
If you think about
it--Shiny, there's
a lot of times where Shiny
has data loaded into it, right?
You can read data from
a database in Shiny.
You can press the
Upload button on Shiny.
But if you think
about it, there's
not really an obvious way that
if a Shiny Server is running,
how can you programmatically
send data to it?
So I don't want it
to read data on load.
I want to just pass the data
to a server that's running.
It may not even have
a web page open.
I just want it to
listen for data.
So the way you would do that
in web development land is you
do an HTTP POST request.
So an HTTP POST request is
the way an API or a website
receives data.
So when you hit
Submit on a website,
your browser is
doing a POST request
to the server. That should
be done with a POST request.
Shiny does not have the
ability--a documented ability
to listen for POST requests.
Normally only plumber does that.
It should have this.
And that's my call
out to RStudio.
I mean Posit. I think that would
be a really great feature.
The good news is
there's actually
a number of undocumented
ways to do this.
And so, again, what
I'm trying to do
is I'm trying to post
the image to Shiny.
So here's the plot
I've made, and then I
want Shiny to come
back to me with OK.
Here's the ID of that image.
I'm like, cool, I
got the image, I'm
going to call it fc, whatever.
And then the package is
going to be like, OK, cool.
I'm then going to take the
user to the browser website
to actually do the preview.
So this is a back and
forth of the POST request.
So there are a number of
undocumented ways to do this.
The way I like the most is
you use the brochure package
by Colin Fay.
This is an experimental
package that
lets you this is an experimental
package that lets you connect
multiple Shiny apps together.
So if you have three different
Shiny apps and you're like,
man, I really wish all of
them were running at once,
you can bundle them all up into
one Shiny app using brochure.
You can also listen to
requests besides GET.
So if you want to
have your Shiny app
listen for data, not just
show web pages, brochure
will let you do that too.
So this actually solves
two of my problems.
One, it lets me listen
for POST data, and two,
I can actually have a bunch
of concurrent Shiny apps.
One for the order upload,
one for the fulfillment,
one for the preview.
It does.
It's so new it doesn't
even have a hex sticker.
It also says all
over it "Experimental
do not use in production."
But here I am
using in production
and it's working great.
Thanks Colin.
If you want to see examples
of the other ways that
are actually built into
Shiny to do POST request,
I have a link at the bottom
and you can check it out.
Cool. So how do you
show the image preview?
So once we have the
data uploaded to shiny,
how do we show the image?
Well, this is actually just
a Shiny app with one button.
What I do is I have the URL
you go to have the
token, which is
the ID of the particular
postcard you uploaded,
I have that in the URL
and then the Shiny servers
show--the Shiny app shows a
different postcard depending
on what your token is.
Now, I put a lot of work into
the bootstrap and the CSS
to make it all look pretty
and to get the margins
on the postcard
right and all that.
I have a whole separate talk
about making your Shiny apps
look pretty that I gave
at Shiny Conf 2022.
So if you want like 45
minutes of hearing about how
to make your Shiny
apps look pretty,
I suggest you check
out that talk.
It was a lot of fun.
So OK, cool.
So we have a Shiny app.
It shows you the
preview of the thing.
It got the data
from a POST request
from R, but how do we then pass
the user from Shiny to Stripe?
Right, how do I make that
Pay and Submit button
send someone to stripe?
I thought this would be the
hardest part of the app,
but it actually was
surprisingly easy to make this.
They're really just two
steps in the payment flow.
First is you need Shiny to
send Stripe what is actually
in the shopping cart
of the user, which
is called the Stripe session.
You do this via a POST
request. By the way,
it turns out ggirl is like
95% just POST requests bouncing
around and this is another one.
It's not the last.
You then also, once you've
POSTed the cart,
you then have to have
the user go to the Shiny
page or the Stripe page.
So Stripe has a
JavaScript API
to get users to the appropriate
Stripe checkout page.
I refuse to learn JavaScript.
I will never do this.
The good--
Yeah, I'm not alone here.
Great. The good news is, is
that Shiny makes it very easy,
I found out, to use other
people's JavaScript APIs.
So what you do is
you use you add
tags$script to the
top of your Shiny
app to a load in
the JavaScript API
and then you use
Shiny.addCustomMessageHandler
so that when the Action button
is pressed for Pay and Submit,
it will call that
special JavaScript.
So it's really just two steps.
And again, if you want to
see the particular code,
you can go to that
ggirl examples repo
and you can see
an example there.
So this gets the user
from Shiny to Stripe
where they presumably
pay money because they
are excited about a postcard.
How do you then
fulfill the order?
So how do you have Shiny then
listen for Stripe striping
like OK, cool, they
paid you money.
Now we're going to go
ahead and make the order.
So we do this with
a POST request!
So we're going to have
Stripe send a POST request
telling Shiny to
order the postcards.
So if your server is listening
for someone else's post
request, that is
called a webhook.
It's just a different name
for another POST request.
It's just kind of going
in the other direction.
So we're going to use a webhook
saying, hey, order xyz,
or fc-6..
Whatever the order number
is, has been paid for.
And to make sure
that people just
don't know what
that URL is and spam
it to get a million
postcards, we
are going to add keys to ensure
that the message actually
came from Stripe itself.
So Stripe will then--so
Shiny will receive the request
and be like, OK, cool,
the order is placed and then
Shiny will call the stuff
to send the postcard
and send the email.
So and this feels like it should
be straightforward, right?
I've already done two
or three POST requests
as part of this talk.
This is just another
POST request.
But here's the
issue is that Stripe
needs to know that the message
was received really quickly.
So if Stripe says the
order was confirmed
and Stripe doesn't hear right
away that the order actually
like your app go like,
"Cool, we got the order."
Stripe would be like, "Oh my
god, they didn't hear it.
I got to send it again."
And here's the
thing you might know
about Shiny is Shiny takes a
while when it's running stuff.
So if you're not-- ah, you guys
are putting it together.
Yes, this took me a
while, too long,
to put together that
if you're not careful,
Stripe will ask for the order
to be submitted over and over.
And Shiny will be like,
"cool, got it. Cool,
got it. Cool, got it."
And the next thing you know,
you have 20 postcards
sent to your house.
So the trick to
solve this is you're
going to use callr package and
callr is a really cool package
to run R processes
in the background.
So when you get the
order from Stripe,
you're going to use callr
to actually send
the postcard, send the email.
That's all going to
happen in the background.
So that Shiny can
immediately respond
to Stripe being like,
"Yeah, cool, we got it."
And not be bogged
down by the time
it takes to send the
postcard and to submit
the postcard order
and send the email.
I love using callr so much from
learning this that I actually
made a whole talk about
using R in parallel,
which is a separate thing if
you want to learn about that.
I have a separate talk for this.
And if you actually want to
just see the code that does this,
again, ggirl-examples has that.
So to actually fulfill the
order I needed to use callr
to run R in the background.
And then to order the postcards.
It turns out there are
tons of companies out there
that will make APIs that if
you hit that API with a POST
request, with a message,
the address and the front
of the postcard, they will
ship it to that location.
This makes sense because
you get lots of postcards
in the mail for advertisements,
so lots of companies
use these services.
Two problems here.
One, it takes a while to
ship postcards, right?
It takes like two weeks
to ship postcards.
So it takes a while before you
actually get the postcard back.
And two, companies that are
sending millions of postcards
to every person in the
country don't care really
how good the postcards look
as long as they're cheap.
So it took forever for
me to find a service that
was actually good.
And so it took two weeks and
I didn't like it and two weeks
and I didn't like it.
And in fact, if
you see over there,
if you see in this image
on the presentation,
it looks kind of blurry.
It looks kind of
like JPEG artifacts.
Like this was a
Facebook meme that
got sent to you too many times.
That was not this
picture I uploaded.
That's what it actually
looked like on the postcard.
And that is beneath the
dignity of ggplot2 plots.
So I had to spend a while,
by far this the longest
part, because I had to spend a
while until I find a printing
service that was actually good.
To send the confirmation emails.
This is actually pretty easy.
There's a package blastula
which can send those emails.
So all I have to do to put
the preview in the email is
I wanted to resize it because
those images had to be very
large for the
printer and I wanted
to resize them so they weren't
like five megs in your inbox.
So I use the package image
magic to resize them and get
the right margins
and everything,
but sometimes there would be
an error in the fulfillment.
So not only did I have to
send an email to the users,
but if anything
ever goes wrong, I
want to make sure I caught it.
So I'd have to send an
email to me and once
in a while the
email system would
have an error in emailing, so
I had to email about that too.
It was a real web of
emails being sent.
So lastly, how do you
actually deploy it?
So I needed the server to
actually be--that ggirl-server,
the Shiny app had to be
continuously living somewhere.
So the place that it is currently
running is on Saturn Cloud.
So Saturn Cloud, I'm the chief
product officer of the company.
And so it's really
nice for this.
I know it's a--
I'm an advertiser.
So it was actually
very nice because I
have two RStudio servers running
in Saturn Cloud in the cloud.
So one was the one
I actually was
showing you, which
is how I did the development
of the Shiny package
in RStudio in a browser.
But I also had a RStudio running
for developing the Shiny back
end, and then I actually
have two Shiny servers
running on Saturn Cloud. One,
the actual server, the Shiny
server, you saw the
production one, but as well as
the development
one that I could
test with and use
like fake credit cards
and it would fake send emails.
So I ended up having
four systems all
running on Saturn Cloud,
which is pretty nice.
And easy.
And most importantly,
I beta tested this
with a bunch of people to
make sure it worked first
and that took a while and
helped me really iron out
some usability issues and
that was really nice as well.
So wrapping it all up,
ggirl is a cool package
for ordering cool stuff.
This required me to
do a bunch of things
that I assumed might
be true in Shiny,
but I didn't actually know.
And it turns out it is.
Which includes receiving
data from an R package,
listening for POST requests,
sending and receiving
Stripe API calls and spawning
background processes that
didn't slow down the
Shiny responsiveness.
I forgot to mention.
So thank you.
I forgot to mention
at the beginning
that not only can
you send ggpostcards,
but you can also order R prints
for your walls, which people
have used for like graduation
presents and stuff, which
is really cool.
And people use.
Oh, by the way, people use like
ggpostcards for like baby
announcements and stuff.
People get really
clever uses for these.
So it's a lot of fun.
And there's ggwatercolor(), which is
just I hand-paint a watercolor
for you if you want it.
So you can install the
package with the ggnolis--
that's not me.
jnolis/ggirl, you can
actually, if you
want to make one of your
own souvenir commemorative
postcards, the code
is linked above.
The examples of the code in
practice from the production
server are at the ggirl-examples.
And if you want to see the
slides, that's the link.
But lastly, I have a whole
bunch of coupons for 80% off,
which means you can get a
postcard sent for $0.50,
which is the cheapest Stripe
will allow me to do before
saying I can't do that.
So if you come talk to me after
I have so many of these coupons
to give out because I'm really
excited for people to use us.
So OK. Thank you.